[Musique]
m
une cage de la sueur des coups
spectaculaires le sdcl center de
maurepas organise un gala d'arts
martiaux mixtes ce samedi 10 juillet le
rendez-vous de mma faisait partie du ffa
a challenge nous ici on ouvert depuis
novembre et ça fait pincer c'est notre
coeur de métier donc pouvoir combattre
pour avoir les gars qui sont entraînés
dur toute l'année pour aller s'exprimer
avec d'autres personnes en france c'est
génial au programme dix combats
professionnels de la catégorie des moins
de 57 kg au moins 220 kg dont deux
combats féminins
parmi les participants un local qui
s'entraînent dans cette salle de
maurepas c'est un bon niveau
il ya beaucoup de jeunes combattants qui
débute
niveau ce soir va être élevé je pense
pour permettre au plus grand nombre de
voir les combats le rendez-vous à huis
clos était retransmis en direct sur une
plateforme de streaming
il faut que ça soit du live parce que
comme pour l'instant on évite les
regroupements de trop de personnes de
pouvoir l'élargir et que tout le monde
puisse le voir en même temps qu'on le
fait pas c'est génial on n'a pas
l'impression d'être des dettes des
dettes encore à hugo quoi on est malgré
tout on a tout le monde qui peut suivre
les internautes ont notamment pu voir le
club de maurepas brille également dans
la cage avec la victoire de l'illinois
maxime flop si oui où deuxième round par
ko ca attendu le bon timing et j'ai
senti le coup et après je vais donner
comme on dit ça fait mouche
donc voilà je suis très content
aujourd'hui mais j'ai encore beaucoup de
travail à faire à notre combat devrait
être organisée en octobre dans les
yvelines avec du public cette fois ci si
les conditions sanitaires le permettent